public sénat et éco des ds vous présente
pourvu que ça dure
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de production dure l'émission qui rend
les co-responsables sur public sénat
aujourd'hui on parle des gagnants de la
crise ou dit autrement de celles et ceux
qui en sortent renforcées
c'est le cas de l'impression 3d qui a
connu un coup d'accélérateur ces
derniers mois une technologie qui vous
le verrez remet sérieusement en question
notre façon de produire des objets et
puis on parlera du boom du commerce en
ligne en france plus d'un achat sur cinq
est réalisé sur amazon alors est ce au
détriment du petit commerce
son patron pour la france nous donnera
son point de vue la pandémie à accélérer
la transition énergétique avec beaucoup
d'argent public à la clé une aubaine
pour nexans le leader français des
câbles son directeur général nous
expliquera comment son groupe contribue
à créer de l'énergie propre
enfin autre gros succès le fait maison
avec l'engouement des français pour les
machines à pain et autres yaourts hier
celle-ci maintenant fabriquer nous mêmes
nos produits ménagers mais d'abord un
autre reportage sur l'impression 3d qui
a fait ses preuves dans cette crise
stéphane geufroi si l'impression 3d
n'est médiatisé que depuis quelques
années son invention remonte aux années
80 jouer lunettes ustensiles de cuisine
pièces automobiles les objets du
quotidien issu de l'impression 3d
foisonnent autour de nous
l'an dernier cette technologie se fait
remarquer en pleine crise sanitaire les
hôpitaux manquent cruellement de
matériel comme des visières ou des
embouts à connecter au respirateur
les imprimantes 3d seront la solution
pour produire rapidement en quantité
mais 80% des imprimantes 3d sont vendus
à des particuliers comme hamouri
étudiant qui a investi 700 euros dans un
modèle amateurs un arrêt centrale s est
créé évolution complet passionné depuis
son plus jeune âge chez lui à maury 21
ans s'amusent à dénicher des modèles 3d
d'objets en tout genre libres de droit
pour ensuite leur donner vie
aujourd'hui il jette son dévolu sur un
vase design
si m c'est la communauté qui l'a mis du
coup à la disposition de tout le monde
pouvait tout à fait télécharger ce
modèle sur internet on l'emporté dans ce
logiciel
ils copient les données numériques de
l'objet sur une carte mémoire qu'il
insère ensuite dans son imprimante 3d on
va venir ajouter des couches superposées
de plastique fondu
au fil des minutes le vase qui était
virtuel prend vie en matière première
cet objet lui coûte un peu moins de 50
centimes
elle a fallu une heure pour réceptionner
ce petit morceau peut tout faire
enfin quoi vous pensez que ça peut
prendre vie et dans est suffisament prix
électrique et d'un rouleau de filaments
plastique
synology 8e occasion en 2020 le marché
de l'imprimante 3d à quadruples et la
plupart des machines sont vendus à des
amateurs comme amaury mais d'autres les
utilisent pour gagner en productivité et
en précision à 800 km de l'arbre à
aix-en-provence sonia 37 ans est
prothésiste dentaire
elle réalise des appareils pour les
enfants alors ici on est dans la salle
de plâtre avant j'avais besoin de tout
cet espace et de toutes ces machines
pour pouvoir faire ce que fait mon ma
petite imprimante 3d
avant chaque moulages en plâtre lui
prenait une heure aujourd'hui sonia
passent davantage de temps devant son
écran que dans son laboratoire
quand j'ai commencé le métier pour moi
c'était inimaginable qu'on passe sur les
imprimantes 3d ce qu'on est quand même
dans un métier très artisanal de plus en
plus d'orthodontie ce tu possèdes des
caméras qui permettent de modéliser la
dentition des patients et de les
transmettre à sonia faut compter à peu
près trois heures et l'avantagé c'est
qu'on peut mettre plusieurs moule sur le
plateau et pendant ce temps là bas moi
je peux travailler faire autre chose et
ça peut même tourner la demie
aujourd'hui ça représente environ 30%
des moulages que je vais fabriquer mais
dans le temps je pense qu'on va monter à
50 et sûrement à 100% 300 moulages en
résine sortent chaque année de son
atelier un retour sur investissement
réalisé en seulement quelques jours
ce sont des machines qui sont très
accessibles
là on est entre 500 et 1000 euros et du
coup maintenant beaucoup de personnes
peuvent son équipe et la machine prend
de plus en plus de place dans son métier
mais la main de l'homme reste encore
indispensable pour finaliser les
appareils dentaires si la jeune femme
travaille avec des machines à moins de
1000 euros
les industriels eux investissent des
millions dans des imprimantes pour
concevoir des pièces en métal de notre
quotidien
nous sommes à salon de provence chez le
leader de l'impression 3d metal stéphane
abed a fondé l'entreprise en 2007 est
lui aussi s'est intéressé au médical
c'est une vraie innovation dans le monde
du médical sont des implants sur mesure
comme cette pièce en métal qui remplace
une partie de la boîte crânienne
en cas d'accident mais il ne s'arrête
pas là il étend ses services à d'autres
secteurs parmi les plus high tech alors
le médical c'est une partie de notre
activité mais en fait on couvre un
spectre très large on peut parler de
l'automobile avec la formule 1 qui
utilise beaucoup cette technologie on
peut parler de l'aéronautique on peut
parler des mondes du monde de l'énergie
et même le spatial en a les pièces
aujourd'hui qui volent dans les
satellites à l'abri des regards une
vingtaine d'imprimantes 3d tourne à
plein régime et sont pilotés par une
quarantaine d'ingénieurs
il faut porter des protections
individuelles c'est normal on manipule
des poudres mais ces technologies sont
totalement sécurisés par contre pour
l'environnement sont et technologie très
intéressante
elles peuvent permettre de faire des
pièces beaucoup plus légère avec
l'arrivée d impression 3d
cette pièce d'avion en métal a pris des
allures organique très design
les ingénieurs les ont repensé comme
pour cet autre pièce d'avion en
éliminant le superflu l on ait trouvé ce
sont les trous qui sont voulus en fait
c'est dans la conception on les fait de
manière très allégée très alvéolaire
pour aller minimiser vraiment le poids
embarqué alors vous imaginez quand des
industries telles que l'aéronautique ou
le spatial
c'est quelque chose qui te suit parle
donc c'est vraiment un moyen de nouveau
que la fonderie ne pouvait pas faire que
l'usinage ne peut pas faire d'aller
concevoir différemment des objets en 3d
stéphane abed et ses équipes
fourmies d'idées et se sont lancés dans
un projet un peu fou imprimer des pièces
en métal à près de 400 mille kilomètres
de la terre
oui nous sommes vraiment aux prémices de
l'impression 3d
à titre d'exemple je peux vous citer un
projet sur lequel nous travaillons à aux
côtés d'airbus qui consiste à faire la
première imprimante métal qui va partir
sur les ss donc dans l'espace on va
imprimer les pièces en métal
prochainement pour soit réparé soit
produire des pièces localement on parle
beaucoup d'impressions aussi sur la lune
donc tout ça ce sont des travaux qui
sont en cours en transporter facilement
la matière première sous forme de poudre
et créer avec une imprimante 3d partout
dans le monde
voir dans l'espace c'est la nouvelle
arme des industriels qui risque de
devenir incontournable dans un futur
très proche
amazon fait évidemment partie des
entreprises qui sentent renforcés dans
cette crise c'est le thème notre
émission aujourd'hui mais est ce au
détriment justement voilà nos
commerçants nos pme ou au contraire le
géant américain
le rapporte-t-il des solutions bonjour
frédéric duval
bonjour david jacquot c'est le directeur
général d'amazon pour la france quelques
chiffres quand même 300 milliards de
ventes en 2020 soit une hausse de 40%
par rapport à 2010 9
est ce que c'est une évidence est ce que
c'est une réalité amazon sort plus fort
de cette crise même si peut-être que ça
vous gêne de le dire comme ça parce que
oui c'est inconvenant inappropriée parce
qu'il ya de la souffrance mais c'est une
réalité
en fait sur le site amazon.fr six unités
sur dix sont vendus par des marchands
tiers des marches en pierre qui vendent
sur la place de marché donc ses jo maso
n'en dirai donc le trafic et qui a été
effectivement en accroissement sur le
side les sites amazon dans le monde et
bien ça a été au bénéfice avant tout
d'entreprises tierces qui vendent sur le
site donc peut-être qu'on peut dire que
l'ensemble des entreprises qui se sont
tournés vers le digital
cette année ont été renforcées par
l'intermédiaire de la crise est ce qu
amazon a servi d'amortisseur économique
chiffres à l'appui j'ai envie de dire
pour beaucoup justement de pme qui qui
ont dû fermer qui ont pu continuer à
mener leurs activités à bien grâce à
vous bah oui la vigile chiffre à la
chiffre à l'appui alors onze mille
entreprises françaises vendent
aujourd'hui sur le site amazon.fr
c'était vraiment déjà non nope c'était
beaucoup moins et ça ça augmente
aujourd'hui on a accompagné des
centaines et par demir entreprises à
démarrer leur activité et on voit
qu'effectivement bien les entreprises
qui vendent désormais sur amazon.fr et
sur d'autres sites d'ailleurs ont été
remis à leur business à leurs activités
de rester à flot par exemple les ducs de
gascogne
c'est une entreprise donc du sud ouest
de la france qui fait des paniers garnis
de produits gourmands et bien cette
entreprise se développe alors ils se
trompent développement physique mais se
développe aussi en digital par
l'intermédiaire de notre site et
elle fait de plus en plus de chiffre
d'affaires grâce à lee commerce partout
en france voire en europe
je crois qu'ils sont arrivés à peu près
un million d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
en plus de leurs activités
traditionnelles sur le digital
ils ont excessivement grâce à amazon pas
simplement gouvernement ils disent on
créé quatre emplois grâce à ça et donc
voilà c'est une garnison pas à l'arbre
qui cache la forêt mais non mais non
mais non il ya à nouveau je vous dis à
11 me entreprises qui font ça
aujourd'hui en france
alors ce qui est vrai c'est
qu'aujourd'hui 30% des commerces
français sont dits finalisé j'entendrai
cedrico dire que 72% des commercialement
le son est donc on a un enjeu national à
faire en sorte que tous nos commerces
jeudi vitaliser on est là pour les aider
et pour les accompagner
autres exemples d'entreprises qui ont
réussi exemple un croître pendant cette
crise la papeterie la papeterie neveu
papeterie ne veut une papeterie qui est
installée au havre vous savez c'est
cette entreprise qui a connu des
problèmes au moment de la construction
du tramway dans la rue dans laquelle
elle était installée et au lieu de
fermer parce qu'ils étaient sur le point
de fermer et de mettre la clé sous la
porte qui se sont mis à vendre en ligne
sur amazon.fr ils ont fait x 3 x 4 sur
leurs ventes quand bruno le maire
affirme qu amazon ne doit pas être le
grand gagnant de la crise au détriment
il a il l'a dit au détriment des
commerces de proximité
vous vous inscrivez en faux contre ce
raisonnement mais non mais moi je
raisonne pas comme ça et d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui je sais pas si vous avez vu
mais nous avons annoncé la création de
3000 emplois cdi en france cette année
en 2021
ces sont des plans que nous partageons
avec le ministre de l'économie et qui
s'inscrit dans une démarche de rose-hill
veille de revitalisation de la france et
donc oui nous sommes là pour aider nous
sommes là pour créer de l'emploi les
entreprises qui sortiront renforcés
cette crise sont celles qui vont se dit
vitaliser en france on est en retard
manifestement 30%
on prend l'exemple des allemands qui
sont en avance sur nous ces paquets la
moyenne européenne pour le coup on n'est
pas obligés de se comparer aux meilleurs
élèves à chaque fois encore que non
des données du cnn du conseil national
numérique disque on est à peu près à 16
17 % des entreprises tpe pme qui
utilisent des deux lits commerce pour se
développer
ça nous met au 13e rang européen donc on
n'est pas au complet et devrait être
voilà on n'est pas exactement à se
comparer quemeneur quand on est au 13e
rang on est plus je pense sur une
démarche de changer les mentalités de
passer à l'acte plutôt que de
financement c'est une question assez ça
coûte pas cher de lancer deux de vendre
en ligne
ça coûte pas cher c'est facile togo
niger c'est quoi c'est en centaines de
milliers d'euros mais en fait on quand
on démarre une activité en ligne
d'abord on paye une une petite un petit
abonnement pour pro vendre et donc c'est
un bonheur de 30 40 euros par mois donc
c'est pas très très important et puis
ensuite on choisit des produits qu'on va
vendre et sur les produits des ventes
on va prendre une fraction de cet argent
qu'on va reverser au site qu'on utilise
et donc il n'ya pas de frais directs ou
de frais à mettre en avant avant en
avant avant de faire des rentes relie
jamais qu'il faut pas opposer encore une
fois le digital et le physique mais
quand on entend on entend lancer quant à
l'état au numérique monia mahjoubi dans
un livre affirmé qu'un emplois créés
dans les commerces ont détruit plus que
deux plus de 2 dans le commerce
traditionnel de pas d'accord depuis les
années 2000 le commerce de détail a créé
20 % d'emplois supplémentaires aux
france depuis l'année 2000 2000 c'est la
date à laquelle harry t'arriver amazon
donc a priori voilà l'emploi à 100 et on
est évidemment aujourd'hui en train de
développer ce set feu se faisait sept
emplois dans tous les commerces de
france qui se met au digital
alors c'est souvent attaquée sur le
montant des impôts quand je dis vous
c'est amazon ne sais pas vous en direct
évidemment que vous payez en france sur
les conditions de travail le recours aux
travailleurs précaires sur ces questions
éthiques cet important cette émission
l'émission tirant les ennemis
responsables ici sur public sénat sur
ces questions éthiques est ce que pour
les recettes droits dans vos bottes ou
est ce que vous dites oui on doit faire
mieux on peut faire mieux non mais on
est moi je suis absolument droit dans
mes bottes aujourd'hui l'entreprise dans
lequel je suis pas 80 millions d'euros
d'impôts de contribution totale d'impôts
par l'armée
toutacoo symptômes était tous dedans est
effectivement ces gens c'est la
cotisation au mais où on met au melançon
de la contribution tous que collecte la
société au nom de tiers ou tout ce que
la société paye directement ses 420
millions d'euros en 2019 c'est
considérable et ça alimente fait service
public français alexandre bompard patron
de carrefour s'est interrogé récemment
se demandant si activités égales eh bien
et un résultat égal carrefour payer
autant d'impôts qu amazon il a répondu
non carrefour payer beaucoup plus qu'à
qui sont d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'amazon
paye le juste impôt juste impôt sur les
sociétés en france est récurrent et oui
oui mais bien sûr et je sais que je peux
vous dire c'est que aujourd'hui
l'activité d'amazon en france et une
activité peu profitables comme
l'activité de carrefour d'ailleurs ou
comme l'activité de leclerc on est sur
des activités peu profitable donc
l'impôt sur les profits est relativement
modeste mais aussi en france chez amazon
est en revanche mais y en a un petit peu
mais que regarder les résultats des
autres dans le monde
mais l'entreprise qui est peu profitable
au regard du chiffre d'affaires qu'elle
fait et en dehors des états unis au même
même aux états unis au total est en
revanche nous payons beaucoup d'impôts
sur les nos implantations nos taxes
foncières industrielles sur la manade la
main d'oeuvre est que l'on kedro que
l'on reconnaît l'emploi sur la cvae
l'acf
on a toute une pléiade d'impôt qu'elles
nous payons pourcentage de celles ayant
fini là dessus chez amazon en france on
a beaucoup de beaucoup de cdi en france
aujourd'hui 30% alors je connais pas
exactement le chiffre mais aujourd'hui
ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'effectivement on a énormément de cdi
que la majorité des deux emplois
concrets sont évidemment des cdi et que
nous allons continuer à développer dans
cette direction merci d'avoir été avec
nos frédéric du val d'ante le directeur
général d'amazon pour la france merci
merci beaucoup
alors y'a pas que le commerce en ligne
qui sort renforcé de cette crise et oui
la pandémie a aussi pour effet
d'accélérer la transition énergétique
une aubaine pour le groupe français
nexans vous allez voir
et oui dans un monde qui tournera avec
toujours plus de voitures électriques et
moins de co2 il faut de l'énergie propre
ça tombe bien parce qu'un leader
français y contribuer bonjour qui sont
offerts guérin bonjour david jacquot
installés ou alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on a une certitude
sur l'avenir c'est que on va consommer
de plus en plus on le sait bien
d'électricité mais si on veut éviter les
pannes géantes c'est lui et black out
il faut rénover nos réseaux électriques
qui sont pas toutes jeunes qui ont près
de 40 ans 40 50 en europe 40 40 ans aux
états unis et c'est ce que vous faites
avec vocable exactement et il ya
beaucoup d'argent public aujourd'hui qui
est là au service justement la
rénovation de ces réseaux électriques
oui en fait on se pose pas beaucoup de
questions sur comment et transporter
l'électricité mais en fait nexans une
société comme nexans transport
d'électricité des fermes éoliennes qui
sont parfois 100 km de distance des
côtes jusqu'à des grands réseaux de
transmission qu'on appelle les
autoroutes d'énergie de distribution
pour arriver jusqu'à votre ampoule aller
et ce réseau a besoin d'être rénové oui
voilà donc ça fait des contrats c'est
une émission sur les entreprises qui
sortent renforcés de la crise pour vous
c'est un business
c'est un business surtout parce qu'en
fait on est au devant d'une nouvelle
révolution électrique le rénover
renouvellement des réseaux comme vous le
dites mais également l'énergie
décarbonée qui est en train de s'en
aller à travers le monde parce que
encore une fois notre futur sera de plus
en plus électrifiée et pour aller vers
ce qu'on appelle cette neutralité
carbone il faut donc une électricité qui
soit propre et là encore une fois nexans
y contribuer avec ses câbles des cas
l'enfant une fois qu'on ne voit pas ça
tous expliqué c'est que depuis hier ils
sont invisibles 100% électricité passe
par les câbles dans vos yeux sont sans
câble pas d'électricité
voilà et donc l'éolienne c'est une
énergie verte par par excellence alors
c'est que les éoliennes terrestres pour
le coup elles ont mauvaise presse enfin
voilà elle suscite la polémique on va
dire autrement pour des problèmes de
voisinage mais pas seulement
mais les éoliennes en mer maritimes
offshore les fermes éoliennes pour le
coup pour vous elles sont grands promise
à un grand avenir parce qu'elles ont
beaucoup d'atouts beaucoup d'atouts et
puis l'espace maritime est très très
vaste aujourd'hui à peu près 5000
éoliennes en mer qui sont déjà installés
on veut en installer d'ici 2030 plus de
30000 on parle de 2
gigawatts de puissance est phénoménal
phénomène est en mer pourquoi est-ce que
c'est mieux une éolienne parce qu'il ya
plus de vent le vent est plus régulier
oui en fait aujourd'hui les éoliennes
étaient dans des distances à peu près 30
km des côtes
bon avec des zones venteuse un peu plus
faible maintenant les pauses à 80 130 km
des côtes avec des vents forts on a
également des câbles d'interconnexion
vous avez des autoroutes d'énergie qui
est en train de se positionner en fin de
ce s'installer à travers les pays où les
pays vont s'échanger l'énergie verte
entre eux je vous donne un exemple le
projet nordling que nous avons fini fini
d'installer au mois de septembre dernier
tout ça qui relie en fait l'allemagne et
la norvège c'est un câble de 700
kilomètres de distance dont 500 km en
sous marin s'est donc 500 kilomètres
mais ces dix mille tonnes le poids du
calme c'est le poids de la tour eiffel
david son poids la tour eiffel que nous
avons installé et l'objectif c'est que
l'allemagne envoie son excédent
d'énergie est requis pour des énergies
vertes qui vient des éoliennes
terrestres vers la norvège qui peut
renvoyer par sa puissance
hydroélectrique toute l'énergie
nécessaire pour l'admettre il ya
vraiment un beau un essor de cette
demande de fermes éoliennes vous évoquez
dans 200 gigawatts d'ici 2038 1 giga
watts et une centrale nucléaire c'est un
réacteur nucléaire alors un réacteur
nucléaire est donc en fait à vous avez
un énorme projet en angleterre qui va
poser à peu près 6 130 éoliennes sur un
parc qui va représenter en termes de
de puissance électrique 4 gigawatts
c'est à peu près vous alimentez 4
millions de foyers
ouais avec cette puissance là mais pour
l'instant il n'ya pas d'éoliennes en mer
en france pour l'instant ça devrait
venir en 2025
il ya beaucoup de projets qui arriverait
il ya ya ya le projet n'est envoyée on
citera ou d'ailleurs en 2022 non ça sera
donc on vous avez le projet de saint
brieuc à north moutier vous allez avoir
à dieppe
il ya beaucoup de projets sur toute la
france en fait est un des deuxième jaune
en europe qui a le plus gros potentiel
de fermes éoliennes en mer mais en a
nuclear mais on al'avantage du nucléaire
c'est pour ça aussi que les fermes
éoliennes mais nous avons déjà accès à
une énergie décarbonée en fait c'est
notre avantage donc mais le mix
énergétique doit aller vers moins de
nucléaire c'est ce qu'a dit le président
est plus énergies vertes
exactement donc plus et fermes éoliennes
a priori sur les côtes françaises
exactement il ya ce fameux plan de
relance de soutien à l'activité du
président biden qui veut aussi un plan
de relance en matière d'infrastructures
pour des carbonnel aussi pour le coup
d'économie week-end c'est une aubaine
pour vous tous ces milliards de dollars
d'investissements oui 2 trillions de
dollars c'est quand même fantastique le
trio ces deux mille milliards de mille
milliards de dollars c'est assez
impressionnant donc le plan by john key
et qui s'appelle bibal better qui est un
plan de ce qu'ils appellent l'america
3.0 est vraiment l'objectif de rénover
renouveler l'ensemble des
infrastructures que ce soit des
autoroutes
que ce soient les idées les réseaux
énergétiques
c'est rien que sur la partie caps à peu
près 400 milliards d'investissements
dans les cinq ans à venir et votre part
de marché c'est assez rare un groupe
français qui une part de marché aussi
écrasante sur le coup pour le costa unis
sur les éoliennes c'est 70% oui
et on va monter à 80 % très bientôt et
je reviens pardon à la france
christopher gorham et pour réduire notre
dépendance encore une fois au nucléaire
respecter les accords de paris et lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique
faudra mettre les bouchées doubles
pardon chez nous en france encore une
fois en matière notamment d'éoliennes en
mer
oui surtout post post 2030
c'est un peu le grand plan des
investissements français qui est en
cours d'élaboration où il y aura
beaucoup plus de projets sur les fermes
éoliennes
il ya également des fermes solaires qui
se développent très très bien dans le
sud de la france et qui vont permettre
d'atteindre l'objectif posé par le
gouvernement qui est d'à peu près de 40
% d'énergies renouvelables d'ici 2030
puisqu'on parle des entreprises qui
sortent renforcés de la crise votre
carnet de commandes il et il est rempli
jusqu'en bas on a un carnet actuellement
kieboom qu'il ya un plus d'un 1,5
milliard on va annoncer beaucoup de
warda dans l'est dans les prochains mois
donc jusqu'au milliards donc on va être
plein jusqu'en 2022 fin 2022 fin 2020
donc ça se chiffre en milliards ça se
chiffre en milliards et on a un leader
mondial qui est français avec des
emplois qui sont en france avec des
entreprises des usines qui sont en
france quand même un peu partout
j'imagine oui on a 60 usines dans le
monde on à la 10 en france on l'a 3000
employés en france on continue
d'embaucher en france et met une très
belle entreprise française oui voila
merci christophe guérin directeur
général de nexans serre si david jacquot
à les autres secteurs qui a bien marché
pendant la crise le do it yourself vous
allez voir qu'à pâques le pain que l'on
peut fabriquer chez soi
et oui depuis le début de la crise les
français se sont mis à cuisiner et à
bricoler quand j'aurai militants
d'allied alors dans cette mouvance voici
un nouveau venu si cette machine et ses
blue et oui après le succès fulgurant
des machines à pain et autres yaourts
hier je rappelle que les ventes se sont
envolées de 75% poste confinement voici
donc la machine à fabriquer ses produits
d'entretien elle prend très peu de place
et les faciles à utiliser et très
efficace et avait été imaginé pendant le
confinement est conçu pour le coup un
temps record oui alors c'est la société
week-end qui est basée à aix en provence
qu'il a imaginée au printemps dernier un
de ses fondateurs se dit avec sa femme
que c'est le moment de se lancer dans la
fabrication des produits ménagers pour
faire un geste pour sa santé pour faire
un geste pour la planète pour enfin
libérer ses placards de toutes ces
bouteilles en plastique et ces
détergents parfois toxiques et puis il
faut se rappeler du contexte
on avait tous obsession un de
décontaminer à fond notre maison qu'il a
passé des heures à désinfecter ses clés
ses courses ou encore son téléphone et
c'est justement l'objectif de blue
emilie nous débarrasser de ces vilains
petits virus
le problème des produits que l'on
fabrique soi-même soins à base de
vinaigre de vin blanc et du bicarbonate
de soude c'est qu'il ne désinfecte pas
ici vous avez un produit sain et écolo
qui en même temps que tu virus et
bactéries
au même titre que l'eau de javel
qu'ovide en tête la machine a d'ailleurs
reçu la certification d'un labo à
s'inventer à strasbourg boemi la
promesse elle est belle mais on n'est
pas tous chimiste moi le premier c'est
pas compliqué utiliser manslois sûr
c'est très simple il suffit de verser
une pression du produit concentré à qui
est livré avec la machine vous couper
avec de l'eau du robinet vous appuyez
sur le bouton vous attendez 8 minutes et
le tour est joué vous voilà avec 350
millions de produits qui vont vous durer
environ deux semaines et donc c'est très
économique oui alors le flat pour le
petit flacon livre et revient en fait à
7 litres de produits finis vous êtes
donc tranquille pour un moment et puis
si vous n'en avez peut vous pouvez
recommander une recharge
il suffit en général de de recharge par
an dont vous faites le calcul à 15 euros
lalart charles ça va être beaucoup moins
cher que tous les produits que vous
allez acheter sur une année petit bémol
quand même il faut d'abord investir dans
la machine qui coûte 129 euros elle sera
à re la rentabiliser au bout d'un an un
an et demi qu'elle est ce produit
miracle et me dit que contient cette
bouteille cette fiole bleus alors déjà
je tiens à préciser que la société s'est
inspiré de ce que fait notre corps à
partir du sel un jeu
et nous fabriquons de l'acide
hypochloreux c'est grâce à lui que notre
corps cicatrise tout seul et donc pour
répondre à votre question qu'est ce
qu'un petit flacon bleu que du naturel
il ya de l'eau du sel et du vinaigre
c'est tout en fait en appuyant sur le
bouton la machine va passer du courant
dans ce mélange s'appelle l'électro
lisent ces vieux de deux siècles mais
personne n'avait eu l'idée de
l'appliquer aux produits ménagers donc
si je vous suis mille électrolyse la
l'intérieur va transformer donc le mix
au sel vinaigre c'est ça en un produit
nettoyant oui alors en fait la molécule
de celle belle séparé en deux vous allez
avoir d'un côté la partie désinfectantes
le sel se transformant notre fameux
acides hypochloreux tueur de virus et
puis une partie détergentes là le sel va
se transformer en soude caustique c'est
un produit que l'on connaît bien qui est
très efficace pour récurer les surfaces
penses-y c'est faux personne n'y ait
pensé avant pour le coup mais se
produisent qui peut être utilisée pour
pour tout nettoyer chez soi est ce que
vraiment on peut bazarder voilà tous les
produits entretiens qu'ont eus dans les
pages j'ai envie de vous dire quasiment
va-t-il peut être utilisé sur toutes les
surfaces qui supporte l'eau alors on
peut citer en vrac le nettoyage des
plans de travail des éviers des sols des
frigos des hôtes dans la cuisine il
également un très bon des graisses plat
un très bon nettoyage en vitre il
trouvera toute sa place dans la salle de
bain pour nettoyer lavabo douche et même
wc adieu donc eau de javel
il sera également utile pour désinfecter
biberons et tous les produits de
puériculture et puis cerise sur le
gâteau david il fait également office de
gel hydroalcoolique résume-t-il en ce
moment petit bémol quand même il ne sera
pas efficace sur les gros dépôts
calcaires élan taches de graisse
incrustés il faudra peut-être passer la
vitesse supérieure avec des produits
plus costaud en tout cas la machine
année disponible depuis avril sur le
site de blue et les premières livraisons
devraient arriver au mois de mai voilà
ses notes et mercier milices hilali a
laissé la fin de pourvu que ça dure les
missions qui rend les co-responsables
sur public sénat émission enregistrée
comme à chaque fois depuis le sacre
lebrun à paris magazine à voir ou revoir
évidemment sur public sénat ou en replay
sur publicsenat.fr
rendez vous bien sur le banc prochain
[Musique]
c'était pourvu que ça dure avec le
soutien d co d'aidé